si bien hoy es el día de sobregiro de la
tierra a nivel global españa lleva en
'números rojos' con el planeta desde el
12 de mayo casi dos semanas antes que el
año pasado y eso se refleja entre otras
cosas en los niveles de agua de los
embalses en el país este que tengo a mis
espaldas el de valmayor en madrid es una
excepción ya que se encuentra el 82 por
ciento de su capacidad sin embargo a 26
de julio la media nacional era del 42% 8
puntos porcentuales menos que el año
pasado y 20 por debajo de la media de la
última década una falta de agua que se
debe a la escasez de lluvias desde
octubre cuando empezó el año hidrológico
tras un invierno y una primavera de
pocas precipitaciones las predicciones
de la agencia estatal de metereología
para españa no son buenas y si no llueve
a partir de septiembre españa se
enfrentaría a un panorama de sequía
histórica algunos territorios ya están
aplicando recortes del suministro de
agua tanto en viviendas como para la
agricultura o para actividades
relacionadas con el turismo esta sequía
también afecta a la cantidad de
incendios forestales y a las labores de
estos que ya han calcinado unas 220 mil
hectáreas en el país según datos
europeos añadido a la falta de agua a
las temperaturas extremas registradas en
españa en las últimas semanas han
agravado la situación además de haberle
causado la muerte a más de 3.800
personas en lo que va de año un 70% de
ellas durante los meses de junio y julio